hi i'm eddie wu and i'm the author of
woo's wonderful world of maths this is a
book about a case of mistaken identity
as a child i thought of mathematics as a
dry and unemotional subject that was all
about memorizing formulas and crunching
meaningless numbers but as i became a
mathematics teacher and sought to
connect this mysterious subject to the
lives of young people i discovered that
it's a practical subject related to
virtually every aspect of daily life i
discovered that it's a surprising
subject that links ideas and concepts
which seem on the surface to have
nothing to do with each other
and i discovered that it's a beautiful
subject that enables us to touch
ultimate reality and come to a newfound
appreciation of the profound patterns
that fill our universe and that's what
this book is all about from the
mind-blowing geometry of sunflowers to
the humble prime numbers upon which the
entire modern economy are built wu's
wonderful world of maths is a guided
tour of my journey through that universe
which shows you some of the discoveries
that opened my eyes to the wonder of
mathematics
i'd summarize wu's wonderful world of
maths as a book about maths for those
who would say they don't like maths i've
written it in the hope that it will
provide you with a light bulb moment
that helps you see what the symbols and
shapes of mathematics are really about
and how they can change your perspective
on everything from life and history to
science and culture i really hope you
like it and that it inspires you to
explore this wonderful world for
yourself